this is an early review this will be
doesn't come out till September 30th
I do this for you guys Schumer yes me
you say that that that doesn't make any
sense though I mean I I don't smoke I
don't drink you know a recycled so I got
a chance to see an early screening of
5015 it was a movie I was really
anticipating because you know I love
Joseph gordon-levitt and I really really
like that the tone the look of this film
the way it was going I got a chance to
see it two months early and I remember I
was thinking I can't wait for September
to come for this movie but then when I
saw it two months early I got the chance
to I was like oh my god movies about a n
man who gets a rare type of cancer and
through some research he discovers that
he has about a 50/50 chance of beating
the cancer his best friend is Seth Rogen
his therapist is Anna Kendrick his mom
is Angelica Houston and his girlfriend
is Bret Stiles Howard I'm just going to
say this now I love this movie so much I
just adored this film it was so well
made it reminded me of 500 days of
summer in all the right ways how do you
feel right now
fine yeah I can't remember being so calm
in a long time would you describe what
you're feeling is a kind of numbness
I'll describe his fine I've grown up
with Joseph gordon-levitt since angels
in the outfield only one kid could see
them oh he was in five nights of summer
inception he's just he's climbing the
ladder he's going to be in Dark Knight
Rises and he's gonna be in Lincoln by
Spielberg I mean the guy's got a really
bright future jgl is so good in this
film if I ran the Academy I would
nominate him for an Oscar honestly his
performance is so well done this is the
best I've ever seen Seth Rogen the
script is so witty and clever the real
beauty of this film is that it's able to
balance such a dreadful depressing
subject with so much humor to see Joseph
gordon-levitt's character reacting to
this situation in such an inspiring way
is such a beauty to see it's just makes
you feel so good about life Anna
Kendrick is great in this movie it's the
best I've seen her since up in the air
and Philip Baker hall is in this movie
and he's in like everything he's always
in like a suit or something in all of
his movies but he is so good here in
this film he's a really witty little
side character and I really liked him
one of your chances said fifty-fifty was
the bed you were a casino game you'd
have the best odds it's what everybody's
been saying you'll feel better and don't
worry and this is all fine in like it's
not you can't change your situation the
only thing that you can change is how
you choose to deal with that the
characters in this movie are so well
realized they seem like real people and
real environments and it's just it's
flat-out hilarious it's one of the
funniest movies I have seen this year
it's one of the best films I've seen
this year I'm going to give fifty fifty
and a it's a great movie I loved it if
you get a chance to see it at an early
screen like I did just bite it like it's
some juicy thing that a fish once I was
a dumb joke definitely see it and when
it comes down September 30th just just
rush out and see this movie it is so
well made I loved it
don't really think that a girl's gonna
go for me just cuz I have came for the
really fun yes
great song totally I have cancer I was
wrong I was wrong I was mean it was
weird it's weird like that it's it's not
to see doesn't sound cool I can't wait
to see it again in fact when it comes
out a few months I'll probably want to
see it again by then I adored the film
excellent movie one of the best of the
year so if you like my review subscribe
to my channel and get stuck mine eyes